I will never name my kid Tiffani every
time I see a kid named Tiffany I'll be
like be quiet
Tiffany be quiet Tiffany i religiously
watched America's Next Top Model until
cycle 13 I believe I mean I haven't
watched it in a really long time to be
honest I'm only 23 you've had almost as
many seasons as I've had years on this
earth that's amazing
Tyra I remember when I first discovered
America's Next Top Model I thought it
was such a janky looking show because
you know it was the first season but
then like I just saw it like grow into
like this cultural phenomenon my
favorite model definitely had to be Jade
because she was a bosses [ __ ] with no
filter and no one will ever forget when
she's like this is not America's next
top best friend and she like went to the
ANTM and like pointed at it I'm still
resentful that Kim from season five
didn't win Kim Vallez bein little gay
Taylor was like oh man there are models
that are gay in this world like I'm
gonna find one of those as a wife Janice
Dickinson was the best thing that ever
graced the television screen on that
show she kept it so real and even though
I didn't agree with a lot of the things
that she said she kept it like super
real like she didn't put up with anybody
including tyrus [ __ ] it's miss J
stolen the show with Miss J there till
the end I hope so also kind of Oh Nigel
hello like so fine and then when Shandy
cheated on her boyfriend that was like
some real world [ __ ] I'm sorry but like
girl your national television what were
you doing some granola bars went missing
and then another girl thought that some
other chick at Nicole who ended up
winning had stolen her granola bars and
so she went and dumped nickels energy
drinks in the sink and it ended up being
like the whole big drama of the season
was over granola and energy drinks the
Tiffany episode when Tiffany didn't make
the cut and she wasn't quite teared up
enough yeah be quiet Tiffany best moment
I honestly don't remember anything else
we were rooting for you like we were all
rooting for you and she's just like the
most upset you've ever seen her we were
rooting for her she wasn't wrong RI PA
and TM like I'm gonna miss you you
changed the game never before was there
a modeling show like this we are sad to
see you go
but we gotta pull the plug and life
support at some point I honestly thought
that you ended like five years ago but
goodbye Tyra we'll miss you but I'm sure
we'll see you again soon Tyra will never
leave us